My breast tumor seems to be a catchy more and more to the underside of my skin.
The rock hard area is getting bigger slowly. I continue to be watchful that my body will try
to expel it through the skin. Would the wound from this be even more traumatic than the wound from a
mastectomy? The person asking this is considering a mastectomy because the tumor is coming closer and
closer to the skin. So first of all, what's the worst thing that can happen? Or let's say this,
what's worse in a breast cancer case? That the tumor is coming out and it's bulging through the
skin more and more palpable and getting harder or that it's going back and attaching to the
chest wall. The answer is it's worse if it's going back and attaching to the chest wall.
So it is a better thing that it is coming out. However, to have the tumor break through the
skin and weep and bleed, it's not going to just come out like this little golf ball and be done.
So if you're considering allowing it to break through and come out and weep instead of getting
a mastectomy, I guess I would influence you to consider a mastectomy because then you're going
to remove the whole breast and you won't be dealing with it. You may have a more difficult time
finding a surgeon to do some sort of mastectomy. If it breaks through the skin and starts weeping
and bleeding and causing an anemia and having other issues, then you may not even be a candidate for
surgery and that could cause other issues. So we've had multiple women that just refuse to do surgery
and let it break through the skin and come out of the day, trying to treat it topically.
And it can be very messy and make your life miserable for a very long time and then they finally
decided to get a mastectomy and probably wish they would have made that decision earlier. So
at least consider that if we want to have a deeper conversation, you can feel free to make it a point